lo que inició como una protesta pacífica
pronto se tornó en un enfrentamiento
fachadas y automóviles incendiados en
unas calles llenas de gases lacrimógenos
y es que la furia de los manifestantes
franceses no cesa a pesar de que los
legisladores aceptaron volver a redactar
la polémica ley de seguridad por tercer
sábado consecutivo miles de
manifestantes salieron a las calles
tenemos la impresión que nos dirigimos
hacia una limitación de la libertad cada
vez más significativa que es
absolutamente injustificada la normativa
prohibiría la difusión de imágenes de
policías tanto en medios de comunicación
como en línea algo que para muchos
restringir a las libertades civiles la
iniciativa forma parte de una campaña
del presidente emmanuel macrón por
endurecer y proteger las fuerzas de
seguridad sin embargo para los
manifestantes es la policía la que debe
ser reformada tras constantes denuncias
de violencia y racismo estructural
vemos que la policía es débil está
enferma desde adentro
hay que reformarla no se les quiere
echar la culpa de muchas cosas no creo
para nada en este gobierno no creo que
podamos esperar mucho de ellos
con cosas de las protestas estallaron
hace dos semanas con la presentación del
proyecto aunque la asamblea nacional
anunció que volvería a redactar el texto
los manifestantes quieren que sea
derogado por completo